[Music]
[Applause]
you see the car yeah but it's great when
you can take it to premieres because
there you know everyone gets out of your
way and it's easy parking for yourself I
don't know how you got in and out of it
cuz I got in it in London and I think I
ripped my Spanx getting in it so I don't
know how you got in in that rubber suit
my Spanx - and that was embarrassing but
it's not to be totally honest the most
comfortable car in the world and the
engine is right behind the seats which
look I guess part of the cool look it
was very very loud while you're actually
driving it so things you suffer for your
art arrabal people should feel really
feel sorry are you rolling solo tonight
we're all shook us up for an official
red carpet right I'm solo tonight
but I mean tonight's all about the team
the group Justice League and the movie
and I'm just so excited you know we work
on this we were so long so hard that it
gets do we get to release it your fans
get to see it it's really really
exciting how are you planning to
celebrate tonight after the carpet I
don't know I haven't figured out I just
did Jimmy Kimmel's
show and that was a lot of fun and down
here and then there's a party after that
I'll go to and you know just by sitting
down I think I've been doing a lot of
talking your cast members were showing
us their go-to dance moves which is
brave our cast members than me this cast
member keeps those go-to moves too
that's why I quit drinking is I don't
want to be dancing like that kid seen
the finished movie X I know they're very
excited about that haven't seen it this
movie just got it's only been you know
really really finished properly in the
past few weeks let's go to take them to
Peter at some point well my life gets a
little less busy we get to see with an
audience yeah that's sort of the way you
should do it that's one of the really
fun things about these movies of genre
movie this spectacle you know we see it
on the big screen because a lot of work
went into making it seem big you know
yeah
[Music]